what's up everybody I am so excited
because today we are going to unbox this
entire Harry Potter Billy Bob collection
from Funko just look at how cute and
tiny hairy is what you get in this box
are 36 baby Bops with 12 different
designs of your favorite Harry Potter
characters so let it rip what we have
here are Harry Potter Ron Weasley
Hermione Granger
Hagrid
Dobby
Professor McGonagall
Dumbledore
nearly hitless Nick
two variations of Draco Malfoy
[Music]
Bellatrix and last but not least the
Dark Lord Voldemort himself
time to get them organized with a simple
Swish and flick
if you're an avid Harry Potter collector
this is something you might want to
expand your collection with it's a sure
win of three sets so there's plenty to
go around for your friends and family